okay start of day two is absolutely
beautiful announce for them today
[Music]
dan and I parted ways he's doing a
community track thing about trolls in
dungeons and I am off to create a track
event about how to do one-man
productions which is kind of my thing
[Music]
Anakin had a staff very confidently but
I enjoyed that and more live enjoyed
academic amatory the really interesting
discussions of paints Jon Cozart with Bo
who was also in the creative keynote
yesterday had a couple a technical
problem this is my background
I'm innocent I'm in a cult called the
hippie boy if you know the story a cop
it's been fascinating my favorite a star
closely by Wally then ratatouille which
your family to love right and rap or
both are we getting there I'll never I
can defeat you crazy clowns to get much
free very nice and that's go to a
workshop fine chef I just saw come from
the transfer from for some reason that
geek now a lot more than seeing a lot of
big youtubers like the fine brothers
about their so slightly the patient some
small Eugene here too
[Music]
so that works on how to make this mess
up show Mom that was one of the most
useful sessions I've ever been to my
life Stefan I think it was he gave it
top really taut work like that workshop
really changed the way that I think
about editing sort of the workflow
between premiere and artifacts I
realized this is really geeky but if
there's ever a place I'm going to keep
that video so the whole works it was
just basically working through how you
edit the site when I was founded by one
the speed very quick earth to to the use
of templates and how they bring
streamline the process and like using
shortcuts on editing and also only like
three people work on a given pleasure of
Phoenix pride from his car pardoning say
as an individual creator I am capable of
doing like kind of thing or you know
what Tom and I over the crash prescribed
today we are capable of making content
that qualification so everything is
coughing you is getting better and
better and practice so start listening
Stefan again thank you so much oh yeah
hasta la cuestión and you were really
great so I'm just back in the creators
lounge and live somebody wants to say
hello to we are we're going to try and
cut your serve and I was just telling
Carrie she was amazing at the credit
show last night
thank you
so after I got the venue for that panel
rom turned up fantastic panel on honesty
on YouTube and mad emotes who I've been
hanging out with a bit this conference
superb moderator really really good
stuff and Hannah Hart I'm ticked I was
impressed by but yet another great
things hello I have my name I had my
name so I got called over because down
there I found Hannah who's also expert
but not actually in acting or in Cameron
he did everyone I meet and we wanted to
her because Sally cellular page over
here we're talking about fun stuff yeah
eeveelution biologies for the word it's
the back together it is an table I'm
editing this there's no way that's going
hey Simon soap you dare editor
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
anybody need a fandom Naughty by Nature
remember those guys yeah
could we all know it's like and that we
have been fortunate to have around so we
are requesting shortly the beeps keep it
light
just a few had a quick chat with rhett
and Link off their big signal face
[Music]
it's been
damn make yeah uh I need some music for
that gladiator thing we did at VidCon um
good come give me a hug
[Music]
did it
[Music]
right here
[Music]
I think we look like lines meetup done I
wasn't filming anything because I was
heating up and it was really cool to be
there three really cool three new
danville recognized and multi fangirl
we're now walking towards the main stage
because they're about Cindy the big
closing show
Oh
pretty great they're the last play these
are they con just closed it was a Duke
women amazing
we got the paint here on earth
[Music]
Jody already had a bit of an effect on
BAM
I mean
[Applause]
maybe
[Applause]
testing me though I think
got to be a link wretch in real time and
even the audience was really good okay
what's your name
deputy from Austria
[Applause]
I love here
[Applause]
I can show the end coming out talking
about why did you let
if you bring
bringing people together
the convention about people not about
YouTube about a website about video a
bit about people and it made me think
actually the whole reason lived on
YouTube enough um you know me yeah if it
wasn't this or Macross favorite channel
here when we here together we wouldn't
be living together so thank you you too
[Applause]
[Music]
so Dan I art where you say oh I've done
that no don't I won't drink like loads
of YouTube people and now we're up not
even baby early to go and get some
waffles I think pancakes Hank a pressure
suit incidentally Amsterdam you're very
pretty
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
you want to touch it
I'm kind of what's the worst that can
happen
[Music]
damn what if you gone for no flavor side
to put together I'll be honest so we
just finished our pancakes they were
really good it turns out that this
places Dana I guess yeah because there's
a huge queue of people waiting outside
we were just chilling at the table
actually goes yeah sorry guys
The Fault dear Brutus is not in Our
Stars but in our queue this is Gavin
Frank House which I've never actually
been in because I mean look at miss Q
okay time to go to the museum no no no
no please stop telling them sorry it's
the best way to travel so far
cute
thank you to the lovely lady who just
came over and gave us three extra
tickets she has very nice work for done
my attendance to this Museum in
philosophy which means we're doing from
placement the local train which kind of
rank with me but if it weren't if it
weren't being chronologically would
rankle me more
[Music]
love
please
so we just did the 1115 hundreds yes
what was your heart of the Christian
artifact you are we have ethical
that heat has McCarthy in Korea friend
as well right yeah I had a crew was very
very great we sort of mean there were
amazing shows that Chris yeah legendary
like external but they were like
brothers are Cara tanking of loss with
the MSS is very much auntie town and we
this particularly liking so no cure
Vietnam are here is amazing
it's
three
so just over there is the crowd for Rev
Run tonight we can be behind it
we have been really lucky to go to some
of the big art galleries in Europe like
this one this is another one checklist
but the Prada in Madrid and National
Gallery in London and you only get this
the really famous people that work like
it laughs anemia in Prada
we never really get asked and look at
the paint almost like don't know what do
you think
don't really appreciate the trust
thank you
I feel like I appreciated the other says
Lauren I think I'm asking it again
looking through the stuff downstairs
just to extend on the point we were
discussing about sort of you know
popularity is there's something of a
fallacy we decided that when you're an
artist you're trying to make country and
this could mean any medium you're trying
to make something that is popular
you know people enjoy and appreciate but
you know that if you make some of this
to be popular people on be produced
they're not going to be able to
engage with you know and it's like a is
like report event in the points are
trying to accumulate on a too popular
[Music]
you may remember a friend at dumb
computers logs he likes to flip off the
camera we asked you found a picture of
him on the night hands this is what he
looks like
you burned that one out this isn't how
rainbows work what do you do
yiii
[Music]
[Music]
I know
[Music]
[Music]
so we look really desperate for a drink
and we've got a bad case of museums foot
which is a phrase I'm trying to coin
well at you're all kind of Museum for
ages and then you just want to sit down
you're not the only police training
standing in like you or your way from
your feet so and we call it quits
we're going to go get a drink and yeah
Rijksmuseum is amazing you've been here
before I know this is my first time and
I highly highly recommend it doesn't
matter if you you know even if you're
not into are just if you're a fan of
culture to generally talk your job
come here because it's really goodness
very well done Museum you know some
museums you visit in this stuff like
this is a it is very well put together
this is one of those places and the
building itself is beautiful alivelu
shop
built-in clincher
ever anything that just says whiskey I'm
a little bit unsure so we thought we
were going to get some beers but
apparently we went for middle class and
we're having a soft blonde can achieve
flatter I slightly become everything I
hate
so far our abuser consisted of mmm and
all that's nice
I was there that was really good I
really like that guy describing cream
another nutty bit like me so what you
looking for cheese and your fruit left
feeling terrible food critics and art
critics apparently if you look at the
color of it it's going to be anything I
think 3 me is not bad they say well I
was that like a mini meal whose triple
star can use going to the triple stack
oh you madman he's not he's not going to
do it no set out that but at that
that's not enough
we're going to some of this unidentified
blue cheese a little bit of unidentified
what we think is some
do you like blue cheese yeah oh I'm
getting it now I'll invert it was real I
have the texture of achieves need for
the case of fun unironic not now it's
just britches rave reviews have
toughness all oriental this was uni
students we shouldn't be doing so we
just demolished the cheese board
thoughts done very good it was very good
I was quite surprised that how they
didn't give as much food it didn't look
like that we actually got a lot out back
yeah that was pretty good even though
they'd think we were a couple
with sharing wine energy board final
word on the Rijksmuseum as we leave why
can nobody paint a decent picture of
baby Jesus ah I think all that either
ridiculous or derpy they're always going
opposite Arabia not even a third in the
picture these are they're kind of like
them the culture yeah and all like
wouldn't have even link they just don't
understand or baby but what's so hard if
you never seen a baby before a lonely
because he died apart commissioners I
chronic baby they're just you know even
the cherubs Nepal right they can do it
maybe just get stage fright
for the record damage has been walking
for the center of Amsterdam to the
station the past half hour or so we just
been singing bits of Handel's Messiah to
each other because we are that cool and
now we can't remember the who composed a
particular Christmas carols so Jack
we've got over the name of the piece
with character we'll let you know right
now
away in a manger
thrilling content here on a final report
we just stumbled across this background
which is not with giant Ferris wheel in
middle of Amsterdam it's really quickly
last night yeah we it was like it was
like a circular saw landing itself at
the view you can't see anything you're
really flying around you're viewing your
vomit Janis 70 wants to do it instead of
contrast in front of us there it's still
way down
away we go stick that makes me feel sick
no absolutely not and the tiny child
going on there looking exactly pop
really lecture oh my god oh no oh god no
just filming it make me feel sick
so just pops into the sweet shop that's
right by the train station because down
ones have a look at this week's
international ones but we're not gonna
buy anything are we
like you
thank you
we just checked in the flight back and
we both saw the Tennessee started
singing we monitor the resistance from
start up said seven she gave me back my
passport with the body part and this
look that just said they're a bit
special on me
very that's like smile that was an
hourglass edited and how many college
around are being I'm doing the same with
the world
surely day for of Schiphol Airport
mining today is so far gate like it's
like Heathrow and Gatwick don't kill
this big and they are huge Airport this
just feels people exhibiting and so will
is having come with my colleague they
are the most pathetic looking trolleys
I've seen I'm sorry ship over what are
they so no he's a madman
you know you look like you look like a
granny from worms with a Zimmer frame
haha
we've been walking for ages we still got
another 2014 gates to go through if you
had a trolley no I don't what being
small I feel like if I look at it from
the wrong angle it'll disappear is
that's more throw though granny nice
little airport it turns out there's
actually a dedicated Heineken bar so
well in Rome charges and with that at
the end of all VidCon adventure our
metal chariot is waiting to take us back
to Sammy access not be sunny but
probably not only sorry but thank you
very much for joining us I hope we've
enjoyed doing their husband amazing made
on the Hank Johnny Bennett watching this
thank you so much keep our weekend in a
not only meeting you in person was
fantastic but what you've done in
bringing becomes Europe has changed that
we I think our YouTube
well I mean I'm just now looking forward
to it
yeah we're definitely coming next year
if you're doing again thank you for
watching and we'll see you around in
more stuff for soon
yeah bye
[Music]
my brother
[Music]